well that's dominic there in ukraine
let's get more on the situation in the
ground there with me now is justin crump
chief executive of a sibylline military
expert and veteran british army tank
commander uh justin nice to see you and
just just give us the latest sort of
from a more strategic point of view
about what is going on in mario pole
what is going on in these steel works
yeah absolutely
as we're just discussing with mario paul
it's uh it's been an interesting
compromise described as an evacuation
origin by the ukrainians it is of course
a surrender of the forces there but
russia does seem to have compromised on
oversight of that surrender process
i think to ensure fair treatment of
captors which is maybe more than
they had initially expected a few days
ago if they surrendered to russian
forces so
but they should be in no doubt that the
azole fighters as it mentioned a key
targets for the russians particularly
with ukraine itself conducting war
trials at the moment of um someone
accused of crimes in buda and i think
we're going to see that balancing out
with russia in return
effectively politicizing the azov
capture and that's going to develop over
the next few days
um but the main fight of course remains
further north and the key thing about
mario paul is it starts to free up a few
more russian forces um for their
offensive in the donbass and i think
they're mostly what what's happening in
the east well then that's the main thing
so um severo donetsk at the very eastern
end of the salient you see there i think
is the main russian target now um it is
the last part of luhansk oblast that
they've nearly captured if you look on
the right of the map
and they're very focused on that area
and one of the things that's showing
that is a signature piece of equipment i
think we've got a picture of
it's called the bmpt
they don't have many of these pieces of
equipment they are designed to support
tanks you can see they have
firepower on the top that effectively
allows it to do the job of infantry in
the russian concept
they don't have many they're deploying
them to severe donetsk for the first
time
and i think it's a sign of how russia is
both scraping the barrel in terms of the
equipment it can deploy
but also is very focused on the capture
of that city more than anywhere else now
so we think that'll be a growing area of
fighting certainly in the next few days
as russia really tries to focus on
capturing that and capturing luhansk but
as we move around they're rebuilding in
isia you might recall that's their
bridge head over the river and the
donets is a really important feature of
this battlefield both sides are having
to deal with it russia failed having
crossing it earlier in the last few days
and we've seen coverage of that ukraine
seeming to have more opportunity around
kharkiv and you can see there where
they're gaining some ground there and
getting across the river and actually
pushing towards russian supply lines and
that's definitely causing the russians
some concern and then finally just at
the top of the map there we've seen
russia come back across the border
they're using artillery
and raids on the ground quite a small
level i think we've got some footage of
russian artillery actually in action and
this is coming from russia back into
ukraine in areas that russia previously
left in the country
i don't think this is a serious
incursion back but it shows how russia's
maintaining pressure everywhere
including with missile strikes further
in the country to keep ukrainian forces
dispersed while russia itself
concentrates on the donbass so that's
the pattern we're looking at at the
moment jim okay justin thanks very much
thank you
you